hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that happened right about
after the game everyone was waiting for
didn't happen you of course know the one
I'm talking about it is now Magnus
Carlsen versus Levon arunan and it is
quite a brilliant positional Masterpiece
now everyone uh was unsure whether
Magnus would uh just bail out of the
entire event or was it just the game
against Hans that he didn't want to play
but now his next game was against Lavon
and he actually showed up unlike in the
previous tournament where mamidaro was
just left hanging in there but it's a
very nice game so let's check it out and
also if you guys have any uh well
interesting comments about what is
happening do share of course that is why
we are here so Magnus has the white
pieces and he opens with the retina
Knight to F3 we have D5 by 11 G3 we have
C5 and now Bishop to G2 Magnus opting
for the uh King's Indian attack we have
knighted the C6 and now Pawn to D4 we
have E6 by 11 cat muscles and now a
knight to F6 we have Pawn to C4 and now
the captures and C4 basically
transposing into a closed Catalan and
there is uh quite a lot of theory on
this of course Quinte four by Magnus
with Bishop to D7 and now Queen captures
and C4 B5 by level one of course the
pawn cannot be captured as then of
course uh well let's say queen captures
Knight captures you are in a very big
trouble so instead after B5 Queen back
to D3 by Magnus and now Pawn to C4 we
have Queen back to D1 and Rook to C8 so
nothing new here all has been played
before and what's more interesting it
has all been played before by Levon
himself with Bishop to a four by Magnus
and now H6 and there is a game uh from
this year's vide Grand Prix that was
played in Berlin between grigory operin
and Levon arunan operin in this position
played Ponte A3 and he defeated Levon
but Magnus does not repeat Pawn to A3 he
actually plays Knight sorry he actually
plays ignites the C3 which is not
amongst the D engine's top 3
recommendations so he is definitely up
to something here and of course it is as
of move 12 that we have a completely new
game so of course the B5 Pawn is
attacked Pawn to B4 uh Knights the B5
and now Queen to A5 putting pressure on
this Knight here so Knight to D6 check
and Levon has to now give up the bishop
if he doesn't want to lose the Rook so
Bishop captures Bishop captures and now
Knight the E4 now putting pressure on
the bishop here so Bishop back to F4 and
now Pawn to C3 uh eleven is already
creating a pass Pawn on move 16. so
Queen B1 by Magnus and now Pawn to F5
cementing the Knight on e4 as the queen
was attacking it and also there might
have been some nasty discoveries than
the bishop attacks the Knight as well so
this is the the way to play it uh Ponte
A3 by Magnus and now we have castles a
very interesting line here would be G5
but this is rapid so of course um it's
hard to find everything but I will show
if something is interesting for example
there should be uh attacking the bishop
Bishop to E3 and now B3 sacrificing the
pawn here and if B captures and C3
attacking the B point now you can just
defend the let's say queen A4 then Rook
B8 and the B3 Pawn will be will be uh
very uh hard to deal with it's okay
after A3 11 just castles instead and now
Magnus plays a capture Sun B4 we have
Queen to B5 and now Rook to E1 defending
the E2 Pawn Here pawn to A5 now
challenging the the B4 pawn and now B
captures an A5 and now the one goes for
G5 and now his idea is all right after a
Magnus moves the bishop I'm gonna deal
with the uh with the B2 Pawn I'm gonna
do with the A5 pawn and so on uh but
that's just it Magnus doesn't move the
bishop he plays B captures in C3 and
this is where the game really starts so
uh how how can Lebon play this of course
he has to capture the best but he might
as well take it into the end game he's
gonna win a piece so let's see what the
Magnus has in mind Queen captures on B1
we have Rook e Captain B1 and the g
captures on F4 and now we have rooked
the B7 Magnus attacks the bishop also
gets The Rook to the seventh rank which
basically means he uh he evolves it into
a pig Bishop to E8 and now G captures on
F4 we have Knight captures and C3 again
putting pressure on the E2 pawn and I'll
just Pawn to E3 and here Knight back to
D5 here Rook to F7 dealing with the Rook
here uh would be would be the maybe the
the more resilient we are just knight d8
kicking with the Rook from B7 but the
one first place Knight to D5 and this
allows Magnus to quickly Advance the
pawn pawn to A6 uh Rook to F7 and now
Knight to E5 a very very nasty idea
where it's very hard for Levon to
actually make a move because now uh The
Rook is hanging and if you capture on B7
now then a capture some B7 Rook to B8
and The Rook a you have big problems
here you cannot capture because the
bishop on E8 hangs and now Levon has the
trade he plays Knight captures on E5 we
have Bishop captures and D5 further
trading down e-captress on D5 and now F
characters on E5 and again you have the
exact same problem if Rook captures Sun
B7 Pawn captures Rook B8 and of course
Rook A8 will win the game for white root
capture some B7 Rook captures here with
check and the magnets would end up being
up to Pawns of course that is completely
winning so here we have rooked the A8 11
of course avoids this and now Rook
captures an F7 by Magnus King captures
and now Pawn to A7 and look at this
position now uh Magnus is up two pawns
which is you know a reasonable
compensation for the piece but usually
not enough however he has a pass Pawn on
A7 or rather a three points for the
piece which is of course I forgot about
the A7 Pawn he has a 5.2 pawns up plus
the past A7 pawn and that is you know
compensation in itself and what's even
more important is that A7 is a dark
square and Levon has a light Square
Bishop of course you will not be able to
challenge this Pawn uh anytime soon the
only way to challenge the pawn is to
bring the king over to B7 and then
capture the Pawn With The Rook but then
you have other problems as Magnus will
start pushing these points he will get
the king up the board he will have
another pass Pawn so it's definitely a
race whether it can be saved uh it is up
to live on to show but very hardly uh so
so Bishop to B5 not allowing the king
test to just start marching up the board
King to G2 and now Pawn to F4 we have e
captures on F4 King the G6 now trying to
get the king to F5 to completely
blockade uh magnus's plans with the king
king F3 and King the F5 and now can
Magnus uh break through here yes he can
Rook the B1 attacking the bishop and
once the bishop moves of course you will
play Bishop to be a rook to B7 and and
uh it's a question where to move the
bishop for example if you play something
like Bishop here
at uh to guard the the B6 Square the B7
Square you just play Rook B6 and again
there's no good way to actually keep an
eye on the B7 Square so you will have to
move the bishop and then you you have
problems if you for example Play Bishop
day four even Rook F6 Checkmate is
possible so you don't want to do that so
after Rook B1 we have Bishop to A4 and
now Rook to B7 by Magnus we have Bishop
to D1 check and King to E3 with Bishop
to C2 trying to prevent the king from
going into the position but now just
Pawn to F3 uh we have King back to E6
now King D2 We have Bishop to F5 and
King to C3 this is how Magnus gains
access to the queen side Bishop to H3
and now King to B4 we have King to F5
and now Rook to F7 check not allowing
any pawns to be captured King G6 and now
Rook to F6 with check King H5 Rook to A6
and now of course his plan is King all
the way to B7 win the rook and then win
the game so Bishop the C8 level and will
try to stop this attacking The Rook Rook
to A2 and now King to G6 with King to C5
and now King to F5 we have King to B6
uh now uh getting ready to uh bring the
the king uh into the position or maybe
just go go after it with the Rook uh all
depends on what Lavon plays King
captures on F4 and now Rook the C2 uh
the idea now is that if King captures on
F3 of course The Rook captures on C8
wins the game after real captures King
B7 with A8 next and then this uh the
past E Pawn will win the game so after
Bishop C2 we have Bishop to F5 by level
one attacking The Rook now Rook the C6
we have King the E3 and now King the B7
and there now of course is no way of uh
doing this we have Rook to E8 and the
Magnus just promotes the pawn to a queen
we have Rook captures King captures and
he was in this position unmove 53 that
Levon Aryan resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
very very nicely done by Magnus losing
three pull full points for that early
resignation against Hans smoking Neiman
but then coming back into the tournament
with this very nice win against LeBron
not enough if there are any new players
who are not Grand Masters watching this
video I will show how to actually win
this for example if King captures on D4
uh your past E Pawn is winning that's
the whole point uh that doesn't matter
what you do after H5 E7 black will at
some point have to give up the bishop
for The Rook Rook D6 chases the bishop
Bishop E8 you chase the bishop Bishop C6
check for example and now whatever you
play let's say King E3 just E8 Queen you
win this uh bishop and now of course
your position is completely winning
let's say King captures an F3 rookie 5
goes after this Pawn after this Pawn if
D4 you just capture this one if D3 you
just give up The Rook for this Pawn for
example King E2 you start marching the
pawn d2h5 D1 Queen you will capture it
captures and of course this Pawn
promotes to a queen and then you win uh
that's the uh that's the point so yeah
very nicely done by Magnus it would be
it would be very silly if Magnus uh
dropped that game against Niemann and
then he didn't uh he doesn't qualify for
the actual event because these are the
preliminaries only the out of the 16
players that are here only the top eight
go into The Knockout so uh of course
Magnus is uh hoping to be in those
eights eight that go into the Knockouts
but it will be interesting I mean if he
gets in the quarterfinals for example if
he gets paired against Nieman if Neiman
also advances because those three points
Neiman got against the Magnus uh really
go a long way uh you know when it comes
to being in in the top eight uh will
Magnus also uh uh you know just not play
and a drop out of the term and basically
get eliminated by Neiman it's something
that we will have to see because if they
both Advanced advance and I'm pretty
sure they will okay I can just check the
standings quickly if you guys are
interested so far okay so far the the
young Indians are leading irrigation
pragananda are in the lead followed by
Magnus and Neiman so those are the top
four so chances are we will be seeing uh
both hunts and Magnus in the in the
actual event after the preliminary so uh
you know the future of Chess is always
interesting what will tomorrow bring no
one can ever uh know we'll just have to
wait and see uh so yeah that's a topic
for another game but I hope you guys
enjoyed this one really a nice nice idea
by Magnus just giving up the the piece
for the that pass pawn and really once
you uh you know it might seem like uh
you know a long a long thing to
calculate but once you see the spawn
actually hit A7 which is a dark Square
then it all makes sense and the magnets
of course saw this like 20 moves ago uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it like I said I'm always
interested in in your opinion on this uh
matter as the whole world is uh you know
just shaken by by what is happening so
do share in the comments I would like to
thank Dustin lacking uh
Marcelo de Barros Paul certanovic and
ante butigan is Del nazia for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event most likely until it
finishes uh so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day